we've got some breaking news and it's a
statement it comes as a statement from
the leader of the Bournemouth
Christchurch and Paul Council Philip
Broadhead he has just tweeted this
saying that a major incident has been
declared due to an oil leak from the
witch Farm oil field and that he has
tweeted a statement we'll get that to
you as soon as we can but let me read it
to you he's saying the witch Farm oil
field in the purbex has been operating
since 1979 and is one of the largest
onshore oil fields in Europe we have
been advised today by The Operators that
there has been a leak from the facility
whilst this has been contained we are
told that oil has escaped into the water
and surrounding areas so there's a leak
it's been contained but oil has escaped
into the water and surrounding area
Philip Broadhead goes on to say that
we're liaising closely as part of
long-established mechanisms with a
variety of parties is this situation
unfolds the lead Agency on this is the
pool Harbor Commissioners they've just
issued a press release with further
information we'll try and get that to
you as soon as possible a major incident
has been declared which results in all
relevant partner agencies working
closely together
Mr Broadhead goes on to say that as a
leader of the council I will along with
the senior Council team be working to
see what implications this leak may have
and what action we may need to take it
is of course extremely disappointing to
hear of this event and while there will
be a time later for anger and
investigation are focused now must be on
ensuring we can mitigate any impacts of
this situation we'll keep you posted on
further updates as we have them so that
is from Philip Broadhead saying that
there's been a major incident declared
due to an oil leak from the witch Farm
oil fields and that all partner agencies
are working closed there has been a leak
it's been contained but there has been
oil that has escaped into the water and
surrounding area so we'll keep you up to
date on that with all the information we
get